ce
[Musique]
dix-sept candidats la droite lui sont
investis ils ont 21 jours pour gagner
nous sommes là nous avons 25 jours pour
être à la hauteur des espoirs sont
placés en 25 jours pour nous rassembler
vous pouvez compter sur ma détermination
pour gagner cette circonscription le
projet porté par nos candidats sera un
projet de baisse des impôts est
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat nous
rétablissons la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires nous on est en
route pour faire gagner la france
une majorité de la droite et du centre
une majorité pour la france c'est la
plus chère garantie de sortir le pays de
l'ornière dans laquelle françois
hollande la place les
[Musique]
les premières truites nord général nous
nous mettons clairement dans notre
projet tout ce que je crains pas
comprendre quand il y aura un euro
dépensé pour la ville est plus que la
panne
il aura un euro dépensé pour la france
nous porterons dès le mois de juillet à
moratoire sur la fermeture des services
publics en milieu rural crie ça
concernera tout l'être
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voulant parler aux français du projet
qui le nom il ya maintenant la nécessité
dans une campagne de clarté
l'augmentation de la csg proposé par en
marche c'est 7%
la csg est proportionnel nous quand elle
est proportionnelle voudrait déjà 0 1
c'est beaucoup d'argent
vous faites 1,7 forçant je vous donne un
chiffre un seul si vous avez de retraite
à 1300 euros
il perd et 300 euros sa femme
[Musique]
notre collection c'est la breloque et
les françaises d'avoir une politique des
majorités de droite et du centre et donc
sur la pompe a basculé du progrès des en
lui offrant la plus grande des majorités
d'avoir du sens ouest est au revoir
inversée noir à bientôt